ce vendredi 13 alors ça porte chance à
ceux qui apportent gens cesseront donc
je vous ai donné va je vous hais il a
produit le tout acheté pour moi d'aider
des grattes aux grattes grille on va
prendre les devants téléphone attendent
et ils sont dissipés à fait prometteur
mais prendre quelqu'un téléphone et
l'ensemble des tickets j'ai rien y aura
une somme est donc cette somme soit
relayée par la personne que j'ai eu au
téléphone
j'espère qu'elle a de la chance parce
que parfois parfois parfois dans ces
conneries là on a on n'a pas grand chose
j'ai gagné moi mais si tu quittes
allô allô allô allô allô
alors c'est dire que halo halo ah non
elle a répondu oh la vache
voyager de nouveau à l'eau vous êtes à
l'antenne par l'eau à bonbons beaujoire
qui est la seule bons soins des jeunes
commencent à l'adil and mobile albula le
pardon la ville alma bilal bilal à bilal
comment ça va bilal pas bien super
qu'elle veut dans la vie
si on termine elle avoue aussi au
terminal comme tara vous passer le bac
était d'ailleurs malheureusement
pourquoi ça se passe pas bien les notes
je suis sans voix je savoir
ok sinon tout va bien dans la vie même
si on sait quelque chose
nom d'un chien un chien non plus non un
chat c'est en fait une interview
et hilal normalement moi j'ai jamais de
châtain sap a jamais de chance je veux
dire à et là vous avez compris un et
alors là je crois qu et sans déconner
j'ai un truc maintenant à mes énormes ça
rien je vous jure que c'est vrai nom un
jeu comme je ne sais pas comment
et je crois que c'est un truc énorme
combien vous avez quatre et non mais moi
j'ai rien ça combien 25,25 euros à 25
euros à temps alors de 1000 euros mais
faut qu'il y ait deux fois m mais l'euro
alors moi j'ai pas dit prête du tout de
fois j'ai qu'une fois vous avez raté
qu'une pièce à ces photos fournies n'ont
pas ni le roannais il n'y a pas mille
orolia 0 sur 4 euros quatre rondes et à
29 ans et ne rien lâcher un euro on est
à trente pas mal c'est bien donne rien
euros alors on est à 31 000 branchements
à mais qui passent plus on fait cela
toute la soirée en ville et à pas de
chance dans la vie d'un héros voit en
vous des poissards devant isabelle îles
féroe voilà 0 les divines wayuu walo
brad a donné gagnant voilà que combien
d'euros on est donc à 32 euros
donc ça veut dire que quand on a 16 ans
et maintenant une guerre on est d'accord
que dans le goal
il faut qu'on ait la même là même la
même somme sur linder les deux mais il
faut que ça soit trompé moi aussi benji
je suis pas sûr au nom mais non tous les
cas et bilal vous êtes là ou pas et moi
j'ai et bilal je joue que c'est vrai
500 euros tu dis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans le goal est dangereux j'ai 500
euros avant l'été ab je passe gp temps
de jouer merci tu brûles remplacer que
j'allais faire